e facendo che progetta innanzitutto
francesi scelto francesi è vero può
stranamente un regalo per te non ce
l'hai mai un regalo per me che bello mi
segue gli amici giusti è pasqua a pasqua
si apre l'uovo ho regalato a te una year
presa speciale che troverai nell'uovo di
pasqua che non troverete tutti nell'uovo
di pasqua è una sorpresa speciale per
lui mi hai messo selena gomez sul luogo
esatto tanto alta così tutto questo se
dovrai però vincerlo attraverso un gioco
con le freccette francesi hanno io cioè
quelle british e che se devo fare lo
punzecchia remake no cosa verità è che
dovrai guarda un po po allestito tutto
il pre gara
fa tutto lui c'è una tavola imbandita
signori hai fatto allora re
dell'organismo guidara una freccetta del
volta l'arancia molti mi colpisce l'uomo
si accaparrò nuovi sono lotto uova
all'interno di una di queste c'è questo
famoso regalo quindi io quel piccolo
luogo sono colpiscono scelgono la cappa
esatto permette la parte e ne apriamo
vediamo chi vince regalatelo fatto ma se
il rivinco attraverso l'uomo
no dai vip parola ragazzi non sono solo
brava freccette ma non a freccette con
le uova quindi ma offriamo momento in
volto giulio da particolare da
chissà se prima facevamo per figlio e
qui è questo ci teniamo ad aiuto così io
uno per uno
per questo diventi del suo questo mio in
fondo si bloccò sì ma non bagni mi sa
che cosa c'entri provini va a sentire le
uova giusto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
certo ma che batte precisione
incredibile
prendo questo ok macchina dell'uomo
ormai hanno fatto vedere l'uomo vi
[Musica]
facciamo così da l'attività di sé quei
venti o trenta secondi trapianti è molto
dibattuto tema ho capito la baguette di
bloccare defilarsi
[Musica]
lei perché si e staccata proveniente dal
male male male vediamo ha detto ho
trovati braccialetti questi quindi non
aveva un per artisti con logo nuovo lo
prendo aggiustati ragazzi siamo andrea
uno per me è incredibile si trovi nel
tuo solo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ti voglio questo quell'ultimo ce lo
giochiamo la ragazza 4 marea casa
concede la possibilità ce la posso
giocare questo elemento io 4 contro 2 e
queste le fregate gianluca rovinare dai
ragazzi siamo 4 2
direi che vale poi non è detto magari ne
vince uno solo dei giovani o magari
non solo ma il tempo della verità è
inserita 35 per cento ragusani la
matematica incredibile nel mentre c'è
tensione il mio nonno era questa nei
movimenti per la casa editrice mettiamo
la vita scalza tutte quindi diciamo così
beh sono stati veloci adesso che la d1
scattate finalmente possiamo trovare il
budget praticamente giorno chiede sconti
ma questa vale scartiamo anche le 32
matic maestria ritrovato e quindi poter
abbracciare questo pareggio la cuffietta
è un po le cuffie dove sei serena 80
chiaro in enormi destro del ghana è
rimasto con il signor o tu e non
capitolo è seduto non l'ha trovata o
portachiavi e una nota cuffie mai aprile
finanza era trattato io
lo vedo io faccio le di archiviarli nota
di bosco bello fare che qualificato per
molto meno male per un insieme biglietti
per la data a milano scarpa vita che ho
vinto melo sono auto regalandoci
evidente rino pignata
hai detto bene i soldi animali per i
biglietti di martin gare si sbaglia
perché glielo voglio dare dovrà
sudarselo ci veniamo proprio come te ti
devo pensare io risultato fa sta roba
io su qualsiasi cosa faccio per martina
non ho esagerato per arrivare ad avere
il biglietto di martin garics dovrei
fare uno slalom non è così difficile
uno sgarro con una bicicletta la terza
uomo ma non ai pedali no no no se tu hai
fatto tutta questa cosa ma psi ma
anch'io ho fatto tutta questa cosa come
facevano i capelli a mettersi in italia
e poi devo dirti che ho chiamato degli
amici
5 guardo
persino grafica accecato non posso
abbracciare i propri motivi abbracciami
trincerate lì grazie grazie
è stato bellissimo farei ragazzini
ringrazio tutti quanti paramenti preso a
pallonate altra roba varia dotto
complimenti per la mira sarà che vi sia
piaciuto ma dieci libri una 20enne anche
la risorsa possono passare per molto
meno
altrimenti al segmento nestore le uova
le trovate cioè linking descrizione due
trovate ci vediamo usate come avrebbe
fatto dante
[Musica]
nessun uomo è stato maltrattato durante
le riprese di questo leader
[Musica]